imagina un país que está compuesto por
solo una isla en medio de este lago y
ahí vive solo un cuate este cual se
tiene esta casa y tiene también tierra
para sembrar pero ahora este chico
quiere pensar de una manera más formal
sobre su economía y empieza con la
creación de algunas instituciones y se
parece cosas que veríamos en economías
más complejas entonces lo que él decide
hacer es crear una empresa aquí pongo su
empresa es decir de crear esta empresa
decide crear esta entidad legal de
empresa una corporación y él está acá
sentado él es el ocupante de la casa de
una casa con exactamente un habitante el
ocupante de la casa y él decide darle
múltiples factores de producción a la
empresa entonces él da múltiples
factores de producción esencialmente es
renta su edificio da capital
entonces renta la tierra para la empresa
da tierra y este cuate también trabaja
para la empresa entonces él da trabajo
ahora recordemos que nuestro amigo es el
dueño de la empresa y es quien pensó en
la actividad empresarial también él está
dando al factor de producción este
espíritu empresarial entonces él fue
quien lanza a la empresa lo que es el
emprendimiento y en retorno la empresa
pagará rentas para esos factores de
producción así que la empresa le pagará
con ganancias esto por dejarle usar los
servicios ahora por la renta del
edificio y supongamos que todo esto
ocurre en un año dado entonces por el
edificio la empresa de la cual él es
dueño el dueño de esta empresa la
empresa le va a dar a nuestro amigo mil
dólares mil dólares por año por el
edificio entonces aquí bueno mejor poco
claro que es la renta del edificio
entonces edificio renta
renta 1000 dólares por año y le van a
pagar otros 1000 dólares por por la
tierra la tierra que también está
rentando entonces mil dólares por la
tierra y por sus salarios
esencialmente me refiero a alquiler de
su mano de obra el salario lo podemos
ver como alquiler de mano de obra y
estamos rentando la energía y el tiempo
de este cuate ahora por su salario
recibe mil dólares al mes
cambio de año a mes porque antes dije
año entonces mil por el edificio mil por
la tierra y mil por la mano de obra
ahora este 4 también recibe cualquier
ganancia que venga de la empresa ya que
él es el dueño de la empresa y podemos
decir que esa es la compensación que
recibe a cambio por su papel de
emprendimiento observando sólo esta
parte estas dos líneas el ocupante de la
casa está proporcionando todos estos
factores de producción para la empresa
de esta manera la empresa puede producir
bienes y servicios y es bueno que la
empresa pueda producir bienes y
servicios porque el ocupante de la casa
a nuestro amigo solitario necesita
sobrevivir
así que tenemos aquí supongamos con esta
mano de obra y esta tierra tú sabes este
puente está trabajando en esta empresa y
tiene esta tierra luego puede producir
comida entonces le vende bienes y
servicios
le le vende al ocupante de la casa
bienes y servicios en particular le
vende comida entonces le da comida y
también le alquila la propiedad entonces
como puedes ver ya todo tiene una forma
circular el estar esencialmente rentando
su propia propiedad pero ojo de chícharo
porque este es un ejemplo bonito y
sencillo obviamente cuando tenemos a más
de una persona y más de una empresa las
cosas se ponen feas entonces este cuate
está obteniendo comida y hogar y en
cambio por la comida y el hogar él va a
pagarla él va para la empresa
entonces se le paga a la empresa digamos
que es decir no hay mucho mercado aquí
porque él es el mercado pero digamos que
por la comida por la comida el pagará 2
mil 300 dólares al año entonces al año
él paga por la comida dos mil
trescientos dólares
por el uso del edificio que está
rentando él está pagando 1200 dólares
entonces la renta es de 1200 dólares y
un par de maneras de ver esto lo podemos
ver desde el punto de vista del ocupante
de la casa cuáles son sus gastos totales
que suman suman tres mil quinientos
dólares entonces esto es lo pongo en
diferente color
estos son los gastos totales gastos
totales y cuáles son los ingresos
totales para nuestro amigo bueno él
recibe mil mil del edificio 1000 de la
tierra mil de salario y aparte ganancias
de las fábricas que no sabemos cuáles
son aún entonces lo escribo estos estos
son los ingresos totales ingresos
totales que aún no sabemos cuáles son no
sabemos por qué porque debemos averiguar
cuánta ganancia está dando la fábrica
entonces veamos todo esto desde el punto
de vista de la fábrica desde su
perspectiva cuál es el total de ingresos
que está recibiendo bueno pues para la
fábrica la fábrica está ganando por la
comida dos mil trescientos por la renta
en total 3.500 dólares por año ahora
había dicho primero mes y después año no
sé pero año por año pero bueno la
pregunta ahora es en qué está gastando
la fábrica cuáles son sus gastos
bueno pues veamos aquí están los gastos
y aquí vamos a pensar en términos de
ganancias económicas porque pensamos en
cuánto dinero sale de la fábrica
entonces los gastos por el edificio por
el edificio la fábrica paga mil dólares
por la tierra por la tierra la fábrica
paga otros mil dólares y por la mano de
obra paga también mil dólares entonces
lo que lo que queda es la ganancia
asumimos que no hay que no hay impuestos
entonces estamos tres mil 500 -1 233 mil
son 500 dólares y es dinero va al dueño
de la fábrica el cual es este 4 de aquí
entonces las ganancias son de 500
dólares por lo tanto la ganancia total
es de 3 mil 500 dólares y que su
ganancia sea
2500 dólares es estupendo porque esas
son sus ganancias al mes o al año ya ni
me acuerdo que dije el inicio pero bueno
y relevante ahora la razón por la que
digo eso es para mostrarte el flujo
circular que aquí existe de bienes y
servicios estos son los bienes y
servicios lo voy a etiquetar la comida y
el hogar la fábrica le brinda los bienes
y servicios al ocupante de la casa y el
ocupante de la casa le brinda los
factores de producción a la fábrica
ahora quizás pienses bueno otras
fábricas no le están ofreciendo factores
de producción pues si lo harían pero no
hay otras fábricas y esas fábricas le
pertenecen a alguien más y bueno al
final del día el ocupante de la casa le
está dando los factores de producción a
la fábrica entonces aquí escribo
factores de producción factores de
producción y el intercambio por los
factores de producción del habitante de
la casa a cambio de estas cosas la
fábrica le da al ocupante de la casa
ingresos esencialmente rentas en los
diferentes factores de producción que se
le están dando a la fábrica y en cambio
por esos bienes y servicios
el dueño de la fábrica está haciendo
gastos que también pueden ser
considerados como ingresos para la
fábrica ahora vamos a suponer que tú
eres un economista si tú fueras un
economista y observas esto y te enfocas
en esta isla entonces serías como el
economista de la isla como le harías
para hacer una medición como me dirías
el valor de producción total de este
país lo podemos llamar el producto
interno bruto ahora como lo me dirías
contaría solo el total de gastos o
contar este total de gastos y los
ingresos totales o esos dos y los
ingresos bueno si contaras es todo esto
estaría descontando triples ya que todos
son 3.500 dólares entonces lo que
podrías hacer para medir podrías tomar
sólo una de estas cosas podrías decir
que el producto interno bruto lo pongo
inicial es producto interno bruto
inicial es puedes decir que es el total
de gastos hechos por el ocupante de la
casa entonces tres mil quinientos
dólares es el producto interno bruto o
podrías tomar el el total de ingresos
que también son 3500
los ingresos totales son lo mismo que el
total de ingresos así que no hay nada
que hacer y bueno el punto en este vídeo
sé que es un caso muy artificial lo sé
con solo un chavo que está viviendo en
una isla está rentando su propia mano de
obra usando esta fábrica está
consumiendo su propia mano de obra y
rentando su tierra a él mismo es algo es
algo muy circular pero ojalá puedas
apreciar como los recursos fluyen de una
manera circular